hello London hi and welcome to the hello
world show I'm Spencer Schneider Bach
I'm Heather downing we are thrilled
today to bring you the very first hello
world show live here on stage at NDC
London maybe many of you have never
heard of the hello world show or kind of
a new YouTube channel that interviews
different masters of the craft in ten
minutes or less to give us a nugget of
information in a visual format for the
visual learners out there in us that's
right
and you can find us at the dot HW show
that'll take you to our YouTube page
where you can see we've got about 20 or
so interviews so far yeah about 20 and
we're about to have quite a few more for
this year we did a whole bunch of
interviews yesterday yes that was
awesome yes
and if you want to follow the
conversation on Twitter you can follow
us at the HW show or if you like to try
to pronounce difficult names you can
follow at Coraline that's me and at
Schneider Bach that's right and there up
on the screen if you if you need to know
how to spell them because I certainly
couldn't if I were sitting where you
were all right
so Heather why why did we choose to do a
live show
well we actually talked about this last
time we were in NDC we started our very
first show at NDC Oslo so NDC is near
and dear to our hearts and we also
wanted to bring you guys into the
conversation it was a bad time we get to
ask all the questions of these masters
but I'm sure you have even better ones
so we decided to give you a chance and a
live setting to send each one of our
panelists questions go to questions
about hwo will moderate them and take a
look at them and see if there's anything
we want to ask
try to minimize your use of the f-word
all right so without further ado I'd
like to start by introducing our
panelists first one is a plural side
author a secure a consultant and a cyber
security specialist and recently
testified in front of the United States
Congress about the importance of cyber
security please welcome Troy hunt
all right well next I'd like to
introduce you to the recent recipient of
the Tekken ista and Spirit Award in the
Netherlands a college professor someone
who runs her own podcast and is on the
board of the joy of coding conference
please welcome
Felina next we have a gentleman who
works for Google on the glue Google
cloud developer team making dotnet tools
for the GCM platform the one of the most
knowledgeable people in the world on
c-sharp and crowned king of Stack
Overflow with recently just surpassed 1
million points please welcome Jon ski
last I want to introduce to you somebody
who inspired my own talk on impostor
syndrome a well-known blogger a
celebrated teacher really is there any
more introduction please welcome Scott
Hanselman
all right
so we'll start with our presentation is
gonna go in this order from Troy down to
Scott and we're gonna start of course
with Troy hunt who's gonna teach us
something today and roughly eight
minutes or less something about
credential stuffing
surprise surprise something
security-related so come on up Troy
alright alright so we're gonna spend the
first eight minutes trying to make the
projector work so I I have actually
spent I think about 45 minutes so for
our NDC trying to make predictors work
so if this works it will be very cool
who's just well I'm doing this who's
been on have I been pine like who is
literally been poned on ever been time
okay so everyone with the hands down
doesn't know they've been told they have
been poned I'm gonna talk about why that
happens can we switch to the projector
please Peter view oh look oh that's my
other screen hey let's do this did you
okay all right cool wow that's amazing
it worked pretty stoked I don't know
what to do next I didn't think it would
work no don't worry alright so at the
tail I'll say a little bit of context
cuz we don't talk about credential
stuffing but I want to talk about the
things that lead to that literally ten
minutes ago I got an email from someone
and I've taken their name out of it but
I'm gonna show you how this conversation
went because it explains the problem
beautifully so someone got in touch with
me and I said this and I get a lot of
these it's like I found someone else
logged into my account on another thing
that must mean they were hacked and this
is sort of what the guy is saying he's
like alright well so the esteem must
have been compromised because someone's
logged into my account so I go back to
the guy and I go by any chance might you
have reused your username and password
anywhere else and what he wrecked me
said it's like this is the least
unsurprising thing ever least surprising
thing ever so it's like yeah actually I
use it in other places so like we know
that this happens we know that humans do
this we know you've all done that I've
done
you know 30-person cetera so people do
this and then what happens is bad guys
create massive aggregates of lists from
data breaches so when you look at
something like ever been poned and we
say yeah there's like four point eight
billion accounts in there
people go through and they collect these
and they create all these unique list of
email address and password pairs now
last month there was a whole bit in the
news about one point four billion
passwords or something like that this
will find it where this came out in the
news and what this was if someone had
collated this one list that literally
had one point four billion email address
password pairs I had multiple instances
of my email address in there and various
passwords that have been cracked from
different systems some really
embarrassing ly old ones as well most of
you are almost certainly in this list
and I wasn't new stuff it's like old
stuff but someone has just gone to the
effort of going around and collating it
all putting it all together in one list
so then you go okay what happens now
when you have like one point four
billion potential credential pairs will
they go to your other systems and they
try to log into them so they use various
free online tools that will automate the
process of taking those credentials and
just spamming them at other systems and
they'll use things like open proxies so
they come from different IP address
they're like heaps and heaps of proxies
on the web we can say I want to route my
connection through there so think about
a few guys like if you're running a
system and you're seeing lots of
requests from different IP addresses
different user agents trying to log into
different accounts and the credentials
are correct how do you stop it but
that's that's actually a really really
hard problem and this is what credential
stuffing is it's just like let's take
masses of things and blast them
automatically at some system that will
try and authenticate to so here's one
way of trying to protect against that in
have I been paying don't you love those
no that way you never been pwned
last year I put out what I called pwned
passwords and what this is is it's three
hundred and twenty million individual
passwords unique
passwords that have appeared in data
breaches over the years and what you can
do is you can download the lot of them
they're all sha-1 hash is because some
of them have got personal identifiable
in fo so so people actually do things
like use their email address as their
password and if the system doesn't allow
that they just make the first letter
uppercase and then they're fine
so I didn't want to put them out there
as plaintext they're all sha-1 hashes
but you can go down and you can grab the
show on hashes from here there's a few
different files there because I had some
editions as I went along
download them all put them in your
system summary and then when someone
comes to register or change their
password or even log in you can say Ike
I'm gonna take that password show on
hash it isn't in the list and if it's in
the list you know it's a crap password
so either it has already been used in
another system by the same person and
it's been breached and it's effectively
like the guy in the message just before
or just by like pure and magical
coincidence someone else generated the
same cryptographically random password
that probably didn't happen right so
it's like someone else has children with
the same name or a mother's maiden name
that's the same so you know they're crap
and then you can do things like either
say look you just can't use it because
it's terrible or maybe you shouldn't use
it and give them the option to change it
or maybe even just like the account so
this is a really cool way of trying to
protect against credential stuffing
that's pretty easily accessible and it's
free you can just go and download all
this I think I'm running pretty well on
time and I want to sort of take lots of
questions because I know people are
really curious about how all this stuff
works
so can we throw to the questions
absolutely let's start with our
panelists you guys have any I have one a
minutes ago and I can't remember my
question for the panelists is ever and
ever have any of you ever been on I have
I been owned have I been pwned
no but your email address in and found
something there I'm not afraid throw a
minute
I did what you're not supposed to do I I
went to the pwned passwords and I and it
says right there don't put in your real
password so of course the first thing I
did was try every password that I have
thankfully only one though any questions
from the audience we have several the
first one is Troy why is a password
manager better is it not a single point
of failure it is a single point of
failure and if someone gets into there
you screwed like let's not sugarcoat it
right but you know what we're doing here
is is you've got to sort of compare
different states so one of the things
that I find people get very upper tea
about with security as they go oh that
thing's not perfect it's no good and
we're sort of going well we'll hang on a
second like let's be pragmatic about
this and a little while ago I wrote
something that was what was the password
managers that'll find it about password
managers don't have to be perfect they
just have to be better than not having
one
and in fact in here has anyone seen
these these password books you can buy
one of these right and I'll have people
tweet me and go ain't Roy I saw this
thing on Amazon and it's a password book
and you write your password in there and
it's not even encrypted that's because
it's paper of course it's not encrypted
but they're they're pointing me at this
saying look how this is and I'm
gonna hang on a second like let's take a
step back and this speaks to the broader
password management thing imagine let's
say you've got non-technical
elderly parents as an example and
they're using the same crap password
everywhere because that's what they do
and you go home one day and go hey mum
and dad I'll give you and password book
and they go through and they change
every password to something unique and
they write it down there and they put it
in their drawer
the fundamentals of their risk profile
just completely changes all the
credential stuff we just spoke about
goes away because they're not using the
same password everywhere they're their
threat actor so the person they have to
worry about breaking to their things is
someone who can break into their house
and steal something and by that time I'm
normally more worried about my TV then I
am like a notebook right so the first
thing is is that you've got to sort of
compare apples and apples the password
manager premise is put all your eggs in
one basket and it's just a really really
secure basket you look after really
really carefully and if you use a good
password manager like
one password or LastPass and you have a
really solid master password and you use
it the way it's meant to be used your
chances of anything going wrong really
really really really tiny small if they
do you're massively screwed but it's
very unlikely next question what do you
think is the best way to get reports out
to customers in a breach now that it has
happened app to that was an interesting
word because that stood out to customers
of a breach if it's a customer you've
got a relationship right so I would
assume that you can sort of say hey you
know how we built that thing for you
actually that might get quite
uncomfortable it's like we built this
thing for you then a funny thing
happened the other day so but at least
you have a relationship there normally
the question is how do I notify some
entity that I don't have an existing
relationship with of a data breach and
that's really hard I wrote about this
actually just earlier on the week and I
spoke about how I'm doing data breach
disclosure and I wrote this sort of step
by step process it is it can be an
honestly painful to be completely honest
like I go round and round and round
trying to notify organisations that they
got data floating around and in this
blog post from Monday I actually wrote
about my attempts to let three different
companies know about exposed data one of
them had a heap of credit cards exposed
now they're going to have other issues
with the likes of PCI but I filled out
the contact form and ID in them on
Twitter and I notify them on Facebook
and I'd put a public tweet just couldn't
get through them so frankly sometimes
it's really hard but have a rate of this
if you're looking for ideas of how do I
actually get in touch with the company
all right next question Troy where do
you get the pwned data from where do I
get the pwned data from most of the time
people are sending it to me and this is
sort of I guess don't say it's nice but
it's the nice thing about running
heavily empire now there's so many
people that support it they there's
literally like millions of people out
there looking for this sort of stuff and
I find that pretty much every day
someone pops up and says hey here's data
I've found it here or there or somewhere
else part of the the scary thing is just
how much
floating around and I forgive you an
example it's done a Google Doc before oh
man he goes your weekend this is good
fun so Google Docs find things on the
internet that aren't really meant to be
found and just in case your you want to
find more Google Doc so you can go to
exploit and DB an exploit TB has a
Google hacking database and you can do
stuff like say I would like to find
files containing passwords what a search
criteria that find files containing
curse words and here we have under that
title column a whole bunch of searches
you can do so you could say what about
well Trello com passwords now to put
passwords on Trello were they dead
silence so you can go there an hour
doing a Google search for word password
on Trello and a bunch of them will be
real passwords the exposed data if we
look at something like say index of and
then sequel doc gzip have done this
before
suddenly you realize how many databases
are just literally backed up to the
internet and sat in directories with
directory listing enabled and you can
just go down and find doc secret of gzip
and it's it's it's just insane how many
there and it's not that I want to show
you where to find out of breaches on
something we're recording right but
there are results even on this screen
which are just massive lists of files
that you can go and download them to
answer the initial question people find
these things and then they go hey Troy I
noticed this this breach with a million
credentials is is out there and it's not
on have I been pwned
here you go thank you so much for
joining us Troy hun everyone
awesome next up we have Polina and she's
gonna draw on the whiteboard for us so
everybody can give her a warm round of
applause hello everyone
when Heather asked me what I wanted to
talk about I said I want to talk about
teaching so I want to talk to you about
teaching and even though I know most of
you probably aren't teachers I'm sure
lots of you do a lot of teaching
explaining stuff to people in your team
to juniors so we want to talk about how
you actually explain stuff so assume
you're in this scenario you are the big
senior the team lead you are someone who
knows things it makes you happy you have
a junior on your team tiny person still
a bit confused about many things and
you're going to explain this person
something very complicated that I will
represent as zeros and ones because
that's super complicated coding stuff so
the junior he's just listening or she's
just listening because you are this
Oracle of wisdom like nodding and
smiling so this conversation ends you
are done with explaining and I want to
talk to you about what you say if you're
done explaining something to someone so
this person has been silence for a while
and now it's your turn again
what goes here I want to talk about that
and we're in a room with a lot of
programmers so it's very hard to come up
with a good programming example that's
understandable but just outside of your
reach so I'm going to use my favorite
metaphor of programming as natural
language and teach you a little bit of
Dutch in order for you to be in this I'm
learning something mode it's that you
can appreciate how hard it is to learn
something who in the audience speaks
Dutch and it are a few yeah so this will
be less informative for you however will
be more fun because on the flip side you
have a comprehensible language so that's
a win for the Dutch people so let me
teach you some Dutch pronunciation as I
said in my keynote if we have letters
they're always representing the same
sound so oh and E is ooh very much as
you would have in book we have more of
these letter combinations we also have E
and I together there I a little bit like
it will be in your mind also by the way
this means egg important fact we have
other letter combinations like you and I
together it's I it doesn't really have
any equivalents in your language so I'm
just going to say I because that's how
it sounds to me although that that means
onion so this was my explanation let's
talk about how I could close off this
explanation to start communicating with
you junior Dutch speakers so one of the
things I could say is did you get it
did you understand yeah anyone did you
you understood it John okay
so I know there's lots of people that
end their explanation did you get it I
do that sometimes as well but but what
does it mean did you get it
what can you now do in probably maybe
you can repeat this but could you apply
it in a different context could you now
pronounce this words you said you got it
so can you pronounce this for me right
close so did you get it it doesn't
really mean anything I have if I ask
this question I have no conception of
what actually is in John's brain or in
any of your brains it doesn't give me
any information about what you're
thinking and also of course look at the
size of this person what is this person
going to say did you get it it's like my
first day I'm smart yes sure I got it I
am NOT going to say no I have no clue
what are you saying what is this really
language so let's not do did you get it
anymore it's not really a good question
a slightly better question would be what
what does this mean what what did I
explain to you what does it mean to you
so for example in this Dutch context
example I could ask you
what does this mean I can ask you what
does this mean
any guessers that aren't Dutch who can
die but what does it mean you're
supposed to know this you have some
context about words and letters because
who it's like cookie so it should be
cookie you could know that because it
sounds almost the same also and of
course it just ends because that's
exactly the same and you remember I told
you that I was AG so from that also you
can deduce that it this is about food so
this should also be food and it's so
related to cookie so of course this
means cookie and egg and it also means
everything's fine it's super weird but
in this context you can see how weird it
is that I would only talk about
pronunciation and still ask you what
does this mean but I'm relying on the
assumption that cookie and cook are so
similar that you can figure it out and
that this is food so that must mean that
is food as well and in this context I
hope you see how weird that question is
but we do this in explaining programming
all the time
we assume just because you did c-sharp
before of course you will understand how
a loop works in Python we assume that
these knowledge that you have from
another language easily transfers to a
programming language I came from c-sharp
and I went to Python and then you have a
for invitin sure that's a for loop but
there's also a for in a list
comprehension which isn't really the
same for so assuming that people can
make that transition from a different
language is it's not really normal as
you see here or useful and yet we do
this type of programming yeah in
programming explanation yeah it's like
your variable it's like an integers like
it's works in Python so it's better but
it's still not very good what is
actually going to give me some insight
into what you are knowing is asking you
to simply pronounce something so I'm not
saying what does this mean
I'm saying how would you pronounce this
something I guess in other words that
has an in it so I can just ask you how
to pronounce this word nothing more
nothing less no meaning and that's
already getting a little bit better and
if you put that in the context of source
code rather than saying what does this
mean you could give someone one snippet
of source code and say what does this
result in if you run it what does this
do if we move on to the programming
world a little bit suppose we have this
code a is five a seven asking in the
first level did you get it would just be
what is a variable do you know what it
means asking what does this mean would
be what does this do do but asking how
to pronounce it could be something like
friends aim and then ask a person what
does it prints see how much easier the
question what does it princess and the
question what does it mean because in my
head I can trace what does it mean and
there's one more thing I want to add
that's even easier than just asking
someone to pronounce a word or to
execute source code and that is give
people multiple options multiple choice
questions has this sort of bad vibe in
education because they're supposed to be
easy and you can guess the right answer
but if you really think about multiple
choice questions about the options
really well they're really going to give
you some insights so suppose I want you
to pronounce who can die I could say how
do you think you pronounce this kook and
I so I'm writing it down in something
that probably makes sense to you
this is option a an option B it could be
well you could maybe also pronounce it
as oak and I
so what I'm doing here is I'm picking a
section second multiple-choice option
that actually relies on a misconception
you might have because in your beautiful
language sometimes okay in the beginning
of a word is not pronounced so me as a
teacher I have to realize I know I know
programming it isn't up to that tiny
person to know all these misconceptions
I know Dutch I know English
I know programming so I have to think
about what you could be confused about
so I can think well either you think
it's good and I or maybe you think it's
okay and I and if you pick this second
option and I have learned something
about what's going on in your brain it's
of course not sir okay and I because
okay it's okay wherever it's in the
world as far as Dutch people are
concerns but this is helpful and this in
the same context of programming you
could say well what what could this
result in well it could be five it could
be seven it could be five and seven this
is a very common misconception maybe
someone thinks it's not possible at all
because the a has already been used so
you can put the second thing into it so
in this way I'm really trying to
understand what is it that tiny learner
has learned rather than did you get it
yes moving on so I hope that many of you
will stop using did you get it or what
does that mean and start moving towards
showing people small snippets of code
with realistic different options so
that's it's a lot easier for you to
understand what people are confused
about thank you you have any questions
from the panelists yeah so that sounds
like great for one-on-one how would you
do it for example if you were presenting
through an audience and do you expect me
to change what I do in five minutes time
that's a good question so it depends of
course a little bit if you're giving a
talk at a conference it's not really a
real teaching environment it's more
about inspiring so if you lose some
people here and there it's probably less
worrisome than if you're in a one-on-one
but of course there are tools like the
ones the panelists
for gathering the questions you could
also use tools where you have an
exercise like this and you have the
audience figure out what it means
because if they already don't get this
then it makes no sense to move on to
multi-dimensional areas all right I have
one more question for you
so when you want to practice the skill
of teaching because you know we are a
lot of doers right we like to build and
then we're elevated to a senior role how
do you practice being good at that I
think that's one of the most difficult
things yeah it's true it is one of the
most difficult things so one of the
things you can do that is not very
difficult and also very enjoyable its
practice learning instead of practice
teaching so figure out what you want to
learn maybe a new language like touch
with has which has consistent
pronunciation a language or a craft like
knitting or whatever you want to learn
because if you're back in the situation
where you are learning you are really
appreciating how tough learning can be
so learn a different programming
language or whatever you're interested
in and I think the ways in which are
confused and not just about the
technical stuff but also that you have
this feeling I guess we're all
recognized like I can never do this I'm
so stupid
I will never learn French or Haskell or
something that's I would have you reach
I think that's that's the best thing and
of course you can practice teaching and
also you can ask feedback because even
though this is a tiny person usually
they can help you especially if you use
something like this to tell you what
they have and haven't understood and
that's of course very good feedback to
you because if I'm 5 weeks into a Dutch
course and people are still saying OOP
here then it's probably more about me
than it is about them and we haven't
addressed that and can I give there's
one really good way of practicing the
teaching side for programming aren't so
Stack Overflow question you're
practicing communication is it can't be
overstated how important practicing
communication is and psycho flow is
great for that too ok awesome well thank
you for Leena round of applause
next up we have John skeet he's gonna
teach us about time fish I'm sorry
yeah oh okay I will teach you about
something I'm gonna draw two graphs and
then see whether anyone knows what I'm
trying to represent and then I will
genuinely teach you about it and while
he's drawing make sure that you go to
questions on HW so if you want to ask is
it that race well done who's that
yeah these are time zones so this is an
x-axis of time and a y-axis of UTC
offset and this is an x-axis of time and
a y-axis of local time wall time okay so
this might be Europe Paris for example
so this is going between UTC +1 and UTC
+2 so UTC not a time zone but sort of
point of reference and it's worth
thinking about time zones in these two
ways because they aren't so different
questions so if you want to say what is
the offset from UTC on January the what
is it today 19th something like that in
Paris you would come along the x-axis
and find you know what instance of time
and i am i representing and oh look it's
got an offset of UTC plus 1 if you want
to find out what the current time is at
a particular instant instead of finding
out the offset you can go along this
graph to January 19th and find oh look
it's January 19th so it's currently
what's the time at the moment
yeah whatever the time is 11:50 13
sorry it's 12 13 12 13 so it's 113 p.m.
in Paris at the moment
but with this graph you can also go
backwards you can say okay I will try to
find the point of at the point in time
at which a particular local time
happened so instead of coming up from
the x-axis you're going along from the
y-axis so imagine this is 1:30 in the
morning I think on a time when Paris
skips forward you would look along and
see there is no that this is actually a
sort of this is a gap so that's skipped
and then you could likewise have going
along from here and find oh look there
are two times at which a particular
local time happened the incident happens
so this may be confusing now hopefully
you'll think about it again in the
context of that graph but basically you
can think about time zones in both of
these ways what you cannot think about
time zones as are just an offset or just
an abbreviation we are not in the GMT
time zone because that's not a time zone
in the summer we will not be in the BST
and if you think pretty s T stands for
British summer time
yeah that's mostly true unless it you're
in 1969 to 1972 in which case it was
British Standard Time where we didn't
observe daylight saving time we were
still on UTC plus one but it wasn't they
like saving time it gets very confusing
the third picture I want to draw is a
time zone is a graph and I'm useless at
drawing things so imagine that's the UK
and in fact even the UK has several
timezone identify as if you really want
to be sort of precise about it but we
can assume we are in Europe London and
that actually since the 1960s or
something all of this so get Northern
Ireland all of this could be considered
to be
the Europe London claims though it is a
set of places that will always have the
same time on a clock on the wall that's
what a time zone identifies if you use
the Europe London identifier you're
identifying this region of the world and
you know what time it will be at any
instant in time what the what the wall
clock will say okay so if someone says
what's the time zone
oh it's UTC plus five no that's sort of
time zone yeah I know at a particular
instant what the local time is I don't
know what the time will be one minute
later okay and unfortunately there are
various rfcs and ISO standards and
things ISO 8601 has you know 2018 - oh
one - 19 t12 1300 plus oh oh and they
say that's the time zone designator it's
not it's not designating a time zone
it's designated an offset so be very
aware when someone says GMT not a time
zone if they say plus zero one or
whatever not a time zone at times only
something that lets you predict the
local time forever until things change
so when you're designing things to work
with time zones most of the time you can
think I've got a time zone ID I can
predict forever but political systems
change just two or three days ago the
time zone data 2018
AE came out there are various time zone
databases in the world and Windows has
its own one I use the Ayana one which is
where the the Europe London ID comes
from but things get updated as rules
change you know back in 2005 I think it
was I'm probably wrong the u.s. rules
changed for when yes when daylight
saving time would come in and I want to
give you a quick warning and this is
also a fairly last-minute as in I'm
reading the debates on the time zone
mailing list because there is such a
thing
people get very heated about this but
Ireland has you know it's an hour
earlier in the winter than in the summer
and traditionally it's been as you would
expect where winter is standard time and
then you go an hour forward for daylight
saving time a lot of software depends on
that that software will be broken if it
takes 2018 a and probably 2018 B when
that comes out and shortly after that
there will be a twenty six twenty
eighteen C that will fix things again
because Ireland has decided that the
summer time is it's standard time and
it's daylight saving time is to be aut
sorry and an offset from its standard
time of minus one hour during the winter
so it's not that it's summer and winter
time it's standard time and non standard
time and you better not assume in your
software that non standard time means an
hour later than standard time that's not
being true everywhere for a very long
time but in Ireland in particular I
don't know exactly what will happen but
the if you read the the civil the actual
political laws and it won't be true now
okay I'm wow this is a first I'm
finishing 20 seconds early awesome we
got some good questions - John do you do
you have an opinion on standardizing
time of if it could work and what would
you like it to look like is it even
possible okay so I think time zones are
reasonable I don't want everyone to have
to say oh yeah
7 o'clock yeah 0 7 actually means when
the sky is going dark for me so I'm ok
with there being time zones I would love
to get rid of daylight saving time and I
would definitely like to get rid of leap
seconds because almost no one needs them
and they're just painful for most people
so I think it would be entirely
reasonable but would be a massively
political difficulty to get time to get
rid of daylight saving time
what is feasible if I'm sure the
audience is packed with lawmakers if
you're going to change your laws please
give us some notice it sounds common
sense um
Egypt a couple of years ago changed and
they gave sort of about twenty four
hours notice that oh no we're not gonna
have daylight saving time now it's like
you can't just do that with 24 hours
notice and we were trying to you that
the most official place we could find
that was the Egyptian government's
Facebook page this is not how laws
should be made so yeah preferably give
us about two years warning so that
everyone you know you know how long it
takes for devices and embedded devices
to get to get changed otherwise you get
the situation I had where the colleague
who was in an airport I can't remember
which airport it was now but as he
walked through the airport different
monitors were showing different times
and when you want to catch a flight you
really want to know what time it is I
don't know whether different airlines
thought it was different times at the
same time site so so which time zone
version are you using Qantas or whatever
good question though
do we have any questions from the
panelists before I move on no thank you
so much done thank you
last but certainly not least we would
like to welcome up Scott Hanselman to
the laptop of you please some of these
questions are pretty hilarious I have to
give it to you let's have a sense of
humor here in London John what can you
sing a few bars from your favorite
musical is my favorite one so far oh but
you say that now instead of whiling
there we have so many great ones we're
gonna definitely send them all to you at
the end if we can't get to them many of
the lines from my favorite musical you
can't really start singing Hamilton on
stage because it's a bit profane turn on
the sound can we turn on that can we
turn on the sound and the laptop yep
that's it all right cool
so I'm totally unprepared all the demos
will probably fail I have no idea what
I'm talking about
so just lower your expectations right
there good can we turn the projector on
projector on would be awesome to be good
I have to ask this question I'm sorry
are we going to have to change to change
the timezone identifiers because of
brexit I change I don't anticipate any
potentially if Scotland decides to use
its own to go different ways times I
might than the England yeah entirely
feasible be ready for it I'm sure
Breck's it'll be easy it's fine all
right cool so I was talking to someone
at work who was younger than I am with
no disrespect to young people they were
actually older younger than my shoes and
I they wanted to know about why get
wanted to know about crlf and this isn't
manse plating this is really old person
in computer splaining and I do it to
everyone so it's it's non-gendered and
it's non h specific in fact one time I
had my family over
from South Africa and they were really
over they were really I'm jet-lagged and
one of the young people said gosh why is
it light here and it's dark over there
and I grabbed an orange and I said
alright you're the Sun and then you're
the earth and then I explained the solar
system to a bunch of jetlag South
Africans that were not interested in
hearing about that and and then at the
end of it I was like why did you not
find that a fascinating lecture on how
the solar system and orbital dynamics
work they said because you suck so so
they said they said hey carriage return
line feed and I said oh well you know
you know what carriage a carriage is no
I don't under carriage is I said oh my
god you should go and check this out
I've got this really cool thing that
shows me that being the Bing homepage
but then when I search for stuff that
uses Google so you get but actually it
looks good and you also find things on
the so I said well you know carriage
return line feed is because the carriage
is the top part of the of the typewriter
it's really awesome and you should go
and look at a video right now on youtube
with ten thousand views of a carriage
returning and I was like it's 2018 and
we're still arguing about carriage
returns and line feeds and let's go
ahead and just watch this carriage in
fact return it's very exciting video
10,000 views I just want to point that
out
so when you say carriage return and then
line feed that like means something so I
went out to the command line and I went
to PowerShell and I opened Oz because
it's better and then I went like this
and then I said copy Khan because I'm
old sample text file type when people
are watching I typed ABC enter control Z
and I copied the file from the console
to local and then I opened it up in
notepad like this I mean I think I named
it N and then went like that and said
look ABC isn't that interesting and
they're like no and I said
I said look dir and I said look how
sample is actually five look how a
sample is five five bites what's the
deal and they're like what do you think
those extra those extra things are and
they're like we don't really know we
please stop talking I said it's the
carriage turn and the line feed like
isn't that super interesting and they're
like no and I said let's open up visual
studio and go Open File and then go to
the desktop because I'm not gonna stop
and then I'm gonna hit sample and
instead of heating open I'm gonna hit
the little Chevron that no one ever hits
because Visual Studio has a really
intuitive user interface and I'm gonna
hit with I'm gonna click binary editor
I'm gonna look in here and I'm gonna say
hey look
ABC carriage return line feed mm-hmm and
then I'm gonna go over here and I'm
gonna click down in the corner of
notepad - which is one better than
notepad and I'm gonna just double click
on the carriage return line feed little
button thing there and then frustrate
get frustrated with that that tooltip
and notice that I can easily change my
character train line feeds in there it
says really way easier than VI and and
then I could go and run that and then I
said well you know now then you gotta
start thinking about ASCII and then
looking at all the ASCII things and
asking yourself why these numbers mean
certain things and go and say like look
10 line feed 13 carriage return right 60
whatever a and that cool and then I said
what if you took two typewriters and
then plug them in to each other and they
spoke ASCII and you could do some plain
old boys what you would tight and it
would print the ASCII on this little
piece of tape right here and then you
could go later on and you could take the
tape oh there's your document and feed
it back into the thing
I still have hair that's okay and then
and now it types your document that's
just taking a ste and then printing ask
and of course you need the carriage to
turn the line to you or it won't return
the carriage and then feed the line
which is super important so then that
would be even cooler then you could go
and take that add that ASCII information
and you could encode it as binary and
like whistle high for one and low for a
zero and you could record it to a tape
player right and then you would play the
tape and that would load the program so
this person is loading hangman on a
vic-20 on a Commodore vic-20
because it's like as if we're having a
modem conversation and I'm whistling to
you except I whistled into the tape and
then mailed it to you with the postal
service and then you received my modem
call as a recording and then played it
to yourself which is super awesome and
then what if we could you know do like
talk about bulletin boards no my
goodness we should talk about bulletin
boards and they were like yeah but it's
20 that's 2018 if I shouldn't talk about
bulletin boards and I think no we should
what if I told you that we added ANSI
support for ANSI art from the 80s and
90s in Windows 10 recently and they're
like hey that's really great Linux has
had that for 30 years and I think yeah
but Windows also has that now too so we
can do ANSI which is like more than a
ski it's got colors and stuff like that
which is really awesome so then what if
I could go out to the command line here
and then run a bulletin board system on
Windows 10 and then go to a boon to and
then telnet to localhost as if I was
calling the phone and then hit enter and
then I have to change my mode because
we're really old we have to say mode
line to turn off local echo and I say
what is your password password what is
your alias actually now it needs to be
hang on needs to be mode
that's not my password
needs to be mowed charm password is
password pass out word there we go and
then I could go and I could do what it
called door menus where it actually
launched out into a DOS game which would
be super amazing and then we actually
shell out to other applications that
that pick up the call and then we wait
and I think that that younger people
don't appreciate how long we waited for
or the payoff and also the fact that I'm
effectively emulating a das board game
with 9600 baud slowness I guess is super
amazing but what's cool about this is
that when you type curl or double you
get or whatever and you see weird
characters you don't understand why
that's there or why they you the utf-8
bomb or byte order mark is there you
don't understand ASCII this kind of
stuff is why so while it may be boring
to listen to uncle Scott tell you all
about why these things work there was
and is a reason for these things and I
think understanding historical context
is good even for people under 20 thank
you
any questions from our panelists yeah
instead of singing the favorite line
from musical can you emulate what the
sound of a tape loading a game would be
in your first computer I I can actually
I will do that right now I mean in
person not no video respect room that's
enlarged that's - it doesn't sound like
that spectrum did you - spectrum person
yeah there we go
if an Amiga was your first you know it's
not save icon
victory was basically like that all the
time you would never stop any look going
by the way yeah I have the question and
sort of a serious question I'm the chair
that's appropriate isn't it our job as
programmers to hide these type of
details so that people don't have to
know them in order to yeah so I totally
hear what you're saying I agree but I
was having an interesting conversation
with a person on my team recently about
the value of learning how to drive a
stick shift before you then switch to an
automatic car and then when we did our -
when I did my talk with Alex Ellis on
kubernetes and stuff like that we talked
about leaky abstractions when it's good
to simply let the abstraction go and
when it's not like kubernetes is great
but you are a less effective kubernetes
user if you don't understand what a
webform is and how round-robin
load-balancing goes the the person on my
team though said that there really are
fewer and fewer automatic cars so we're
getting to the point where we will
eventually be able to get rid of manual
shifts but that's only because automatic
cars have recently gotten to the point
where the gas mileage is is the same as
manual so there's really no reason but
another question would be if you're
gonna have a watch would you have a
digital watch during automatic watch if
you have a child would you teach the
child how to read a clock or did you
just say an analog is over it's all just
digital there's no reason to learn clock
hands there's no reason to learn cursive
I think that historical context at least
a floating window of the last hundred
years has value so when I teach people
how to program I tend to teach from the
metal up I'll teach him Alec I'll teach
him free
I'll make them suffer
and then I'll be like a garbage
collection but if you start with garbage
collection you tend to make a lot of
garbage and if you don't know what's
come before you can't avoid making the
same mistakes again someone will say all
this this automatic stuff imagine if we
could just manually change gears how
also that would be but I think the point
is I think the point I think that two
fillings point yes with you there's
value in hiding the abstractions but I
still think that there's some I don't
know I remember when I didn't have a
pocket supercomputer that I talked to
strangers about cats on this is the sum
total of all human knowledge and I've
seen all three episodes of black mirror
that talk about this kind of stuff
and I think if we don't understand
history we are gonna get nailed so I
think that computer science 101 should
be followed by computer science history
101 I'm afraid that it isn't it makes me
sad it's not about old people saying
yeah remember when I was old I think
it's about like hey this is this right
here watching this screen this is why
you should minify your JavaScript
because that's a great question thank
you awesome thank you Scott training all
right we got a couple of questions that
we'd like to ask all four of you alright
wait I got an answer from each that's
alright and we'll start with this one I
would worry about sounding condescending
while explaining things so how do you
avoid this in your life I asked them
beforehand if they want me to explain to
them if they're in their teens they have
to listen to me but if they are my
professional colleagues and I just say
oh are you familiar with that and I go
yes I take their word for it I probably
screw up so I just explicitly
consciously try not to be condescending
and hopefully so while you're talking to
someone whether it's via comments on the
internet or in person and keeping eye
contact and try to pick up on verbal
cues that you're losing people whether
that's because you're being boring or
condescending or whatever it is all
right oh yeah I could I can leave
condescending boring and wrong all at
the same time
and you still get uploads what do you
say try I think for me like I I tried
their stuff in person because I think
you lose a lot of context online like
online there's always gonna be so many
things you're an idiot and Oh matter how
hard you try not to be sometimes a trial
to me but yeah like I just try and do
stuff in person and I was also speak to
people on the phone sometimes as well
there's still fines by the way he can
still use them they work well yeah I
think if you're explaining something in
natural state that you get in is sending
if you try if you're preparing at all
for example you will be like what am I
going to share and sharing is fun
because you know stuff so and it takes a
while I think to practice but after a
while you can get in this mode where
teaching is more about listening than it
is about sharing and I think then it's
easier and also be condescending because
you're way more trying to listen to them
a little bit like going back to what I
was sharing notes pain here some
knowledge but what do you already know
about this and then I can go a little
bit higher and then I will be closer so
probably let's go in the same it's very
tricky it's a very good question because
it's so easy to share stuff that people
don't care about or already know I love
what you just said we're not trying to
teach this stuff I'll ask them how do
you how would you have done this given
this problem with carries returns are
asking how would you design it and then
I explained how it was designed and then
they can criticize it inside because
it's okay to have this opinions
yeah that's great all right so for the
last one it's kind of important one
because now we are globally connected
right so maybe your team is not in a
place where you can be face to face so
what is the one thing that each of you
do to get a better quality of connection
with your team members that are remote
well failing to use Skype for business
we then fall back on
Mineola okay so you should probably ask
my colleagues who are out there but we
we don't use a slack channel but we do
use hangout chat so people are always
available in text form during working
times yeah I don't expect my colleagues
to always always be there and you don't
need to tell me if you're going shopping
or whatever so you have realistic
reasonable expectations that include
work-life balance and be ready to switch
to the most appropriate form so starts
off with a chat and then say actually I
could do with some more back and forth
without all the tapping can we have a VC
and then we'll just hop on a hangout and
if you're always prepared for that sort
of scale of different communications it
helps so I want to properly credit this
idea to Allah when Allah
Llewelyn Falco because he gave it to me
I started doing learning hour with my
team when we take one hour of learning
every week one of the team members
prepare something that they want to talk
about an arrest learn and it could be
tech stuff but it could also be how you
do calendar management or whatever and
this for me has really made my team like
closer they're all like I want to talk
about this and I want to talk about that
and it equalizes I think and also it
keeps you in this learning mode we'll
also what will also make you a better
teacher intervention I solved the
problem of needing to communicate the
team member by getting fired from my job
and I can't recommend it highly enough
thank you guys so much for joining us on
the hello world show life thank you guys
for your questions
thank you yes you've been an excellent
audience thank you London for being so
welcoming and one more round of applause
for our panelists thank you very much
[Applause]